today's video is brought to you by Magic
spoon cereal reinvented more about them
in a bit like all the other countries
that suffered the occupation of their
country's fine artsy Germany during
World War II France proudly remembers
those men and women who bravely fought
against their oppressors the members of
the French Resistance however few
Compliments are paid to their opposite
numbers those who willingly cooperated
with the Germans and helped them achieve
their goals of all those tarred with a
label collaborators none is more
Infamous than the leader of the puppet
state set up in France in the wake of
the German occupation Marshall Philippe
petone what made potasse betrayal so
shocking was that he didn't seem the
type he was a war hero one of the
Victorious generals of the first world
war awarded the highest honors and
beloved by his countrymen of course
baton didn't view what he was doing as a
betrayal at all he believed he was
saving his beloved France from an even
worse fate that by cooperating with the
Germans they would eventually leave them
alone and they could go back to business
as usual despite his high ideals patal's
Vichy regime took on many of the West
characteristics of their Nazi occupiers
and offered a bleak picture of what the
future of France might have looked like
if the Allies hadn't eventually won the
war far from saving France many people
accused petor of destroying it when
World War one broke out in 1914 Philip
baton was at the end of a long and
unremarkable Army Career born to a
peasant farming family in 1856 petore
had joined the army after briefly
entertaining the idea of becoming a
Catholic priest he graduated from the
military academy he had sarcia in 1878
and was commissioned as an officer in an
army that was still reeling from the
humiliating defeat of the
franco-prussian war in 1870. young
officers like patar who had been too
young to serve back then burned for a
chance to get revenge on Germany to
regain the honor of France through
another more Victorious War over 30
years after entering service however
that all seemed unlikely to ever happen
and it appeared more and more certain
that petal would spend his entire career
without ever hearing a shot fired in
anger on the battlefield he'll Advance
slowly in rank achieving the rank of
Colonel in 1911 but being told that he
would go no further by the time he
reached the mandatory retirement age of
60 in 1916. Petal had also never married
and started a family of his own several
engagement suits had failed because
middling Army prospects and the
reputation he had for sleeping with
other men's wives it seemed that orbitar
had to look forward to was a lonely
retirement and a small pension but then
Archduke Franz Ferdinand was
assassinated in Sarajevo tipping over
the first domino in an Unstoppable chain
who eventually see all of Europe's major
Powers at war with each other
foreign
Germany invaded Belgium in August 1914
bypassing the massive defensive
positions of the French army along the
German border and advancing deeper to
France it seemed like Paris itself might
fall the commander-in-chief of the
French force is General Joseph joffre
managed to stabilize the situation and
working in concert with the British and
Belgian armies stopped the German
advance in the first battle of the man
during this fight and in the
counter-offensives that followed Joffrey
understood a full-scale purge of
high-ranking Military Officers that he
believed weren't up to the task hundreds
of officers were dismissed or reassigned
this reorganization proved a boon to
Patel who in the span of a single year
went from a colonel commanding a brigade
to a three-star General commanding the
entire French second Army he was
certainly no Napoleon but he was an able
commander who inspired his men by
visiting them at the front speaking to
them in the regional Patois of his
birthplace rather than the educated
Parisian accent used by most senior
officers the men trusted general patar
which was important because at the end
of 14 The War of maneuver had settled
down into the horrors of trench warfare
a new kind of combat never employed on
such a large scale before none of the
19th century tactics the generals of the
day had been schooled in worked against
the new weapons employed on the Western
Front machine guns barbed wire poison
gas and massive artillery guns that
could fire from Miles Away ah breakfast
the most important meal of the day right
and delicious with magic spoon
sometimes breakfast can be a little
boring same old cereal
finish my mouth ball same old milk I
mean who doesn't love a wholesome
breakfast and that's where magic spoon
comes in Magic spoon brings you the
childlike Nostalgia of Saturday morning
cartoons upgraded for the 21st century
with flavors like Coco fruity and peanut
butter and all these other ones they
just sent me these there's the fruited
one there's peanut butter so they've got
birthday cake Flavor now cinnamon roll
so many flavors with 13 grams of protein
and 45 grams of net carbs per serving
you'll be fueling your body as well and
the best part these never boring flavors
zero grams of total sugars that's right
no cane sugar no corn syrup no sugar
alcohols except for honey not that has
one
but don't just take my word for it build
your very own variety box with flavors
like frosted cookies and cream and
blueberry muffin there's the birthday
cake I haven't actually tried that I'm
quite Keen my favorite flavor peanut
butter right there and uh yeah get that
added add that to your box if you're
into peanut butter even if you're nice
really really good and look if you're
worried about gluten or grains don't be
magic spoon is gluten free and it's
grain free plus there are no artificial
colors or sweeteners just natural
flavors that you endure in a child will
love so click the link below and use the
code biographics for five dollars off or
go to magicspoon.com biographics to save
five dollars off your first order and
they've also got 100 happiness guarantee
so you can try it risk free and even if
you're in the UK or Canada they'll ship
to you as well so build your own box
there's a link below and now back to
today's video neither side could shift
the line of battle the only thing that
changed was the ever increasing number
of men who died petal was one of the few
high-ranking officers to realize that
the current military situation did not
allow for a glorious breakthrough of the
German lines and that this was about of
attrition that could only be won when
one side got tired of the killing this
was typified at the Battle of adol in
which Patong commanded French forces in
the center of the Western Front the
Germans attacked at Verdon not to seize
a position but to bleed France white by
inflicting so many casualties of the
country couldn't continue the war Qatar
recognized this and turned the tables on
the Germans declaring that he would hold
his ground and let the Germans come to
him in the open so that he could destroy
them the same trenches owa fought over
again and again with both sides taking
appalling losses to keep morale up
batard built a road to Vidal the boy
sacred that constantly ferried men and
supplies that built divisions were on
the front lines for only a week or two
before being replaced by fresh units
eventually almost the entirety of the
army served a Vadar during the
10-month-long battle which made the doll
symbolic of the entire War for the
French people and the Army it was also
symbolic of the uselessness of the whole
Affair despite a combined 800 000
casualties nothing of consequence was
gained by either side if anyone had won
the battle of it was General Patton who
became the hero of France and gained a
sparkling reputation for Valor that he
would bask in for the rest of his life
[Music]
in 1917 the French army was in trouble
after yet another for ild assault by the
Allies the troops were on the verge of
mutiny almost half the French units on
the Western Front were engaged in
various forms of Disobedience refusing
to leave their trenches abandoning their
posts ignoring orders even attacking
their officers if morale dipped any
further the war would be lost button now
commander-in-chief of French forces
following shafra's retirement and the
dismissal of General Robert Neville knew
that he had to do something he told the
front lines promising better treatment
of his soldiers exhausted units were
sent to the rear to rest or home leave
was granted and conditions in the
trenches improved most important of all
no more Mast assaults patan was
determined to hold the line until
sufficient numbers of another new weapon
the tank were produced as oil as the
arrival of the American expeditionary
Force following the United States as
entry into the war he also had 49
mutineers executed by firing squad in
1918 the Germans mounted a series of
desperate assaults on the Western Front
trying to defeat the allies before the
Americans arrived in strength the first
assault threat him to split the British
expeditionary Force commanded by field
Marshal Hague from the French army which
would cause it to be destroyed tar who
greatly disliked Hague seemed willing to
let the British be destroyed until he
was ordered to come to their aid by the
new Supreme Allied Commander Ferdinand
fosh this animosity towards the British
would rear its head again in later
decades still this mistake was forgotten
in the glory of Victories the German
offensives were stopped and the Allies
pushed back bolstered now by American
sport the Germans meanwhile had no
resources left they'd run out meta
material an Armistice was agreed on
November the 11th ending the war to end
all wars baton was made Marshall of
France 10 days after the end of the war
one of three alongside farsh and jafra
and for the rest of his life he would be
addressed as Marshall baton he relished
his role as a war hero continuing
actor's service until 1928. that
decade's orbital overseeing a Army in
transition from war to peace and like
many generals he was unhappy about the
severe defense Cuts enacted by the
government but in all honesty they had
no choice the war had nearly bankrupted
France four percent of the population
had been killed and much of her industry
destroyed or damaged instead of relying
on a large field Army for defense the
country instead would build a series of
strong fortifications the magino line
which would guard the border between
France and Germany outside of the
military patar also enjoyed an active
social life he had finally gotten
married in 1920. supposedly one of his
Mistresses Eugenie Nini hardor had
threatened him with a gun until he
finally agreed to tie the knot the
marriage would not be a particularly
happy one because Nini was a divorced
woman baton's marriage to her was not
recognized by the Catholic Church polite
society would not accept her so patal
usually attended events and Gatherings
by himself most of the guests Batar
entertained at home never saw her either
as she was kept in her own separate
apartment from the Marshall
if martial guitar had died before World
War II broke out it is likely that it
would remain one of France's most
revered war heroes with statues and
commemorations to him all over the
country but unfortunately for him he
didn't instead he lived long enough to
see his hard-won reputation brought to
ruin Batar was not in France When The
War Began instead serving as France's
ambassador to Spain and Madrid by the
time he was recalled to Paris in May
1940 the country was in crisis Germany
had invaded France not through Belgium
as expected but through a gap in Allied
defenses in the Arden Forest thought to
be impossible tanks this move cut off
the British expeditionary force and a
chunk of the French army from the rest
of the Allied armies which was
surrounded at the Port of Dunkirk the
Germans had mastered a new style of
warfare the Blitzkrieg or lightning War
while the British and French commanders
had expected the conflict to play out
similarly to the first world war 20
years earlier along with other ministers
soon came to believe the war was lost
and that the best thing they could do
now was to seek an Armistice with the
Germans on as favorable terms as
possible after Prime Minister Paul
Renault resigned the task fell to Batar
who agreed to the humiliating terms on
June 22nd 60 of the country was to be
occupied by German and Italian troops
including Paris the remainder would be
self-governing and the government chose
the resort town of Vichy as a seat of
government in the Free Zone this was to
be a temporary State of Affairs only
until Britain now fighting along against
the Axis powers came to terms which was
expected imminently after all if Mighty
power like France had collapsed in the
face of the Nazi Onslaught what chance
did the British have
on July the 10th 1940 the French
Parliament met in Vichy and voted itself
out of existence the third Republic was
replaced by an autocratic French state
with Marshall batana's head baton
believed that this was the only way to
ensure order in France while the Germans
still occupied half the country
comparing himself to a Roman dictator
during the Republican era who assumed
emergency powers to save the nation
petal and others believed that one of
the key reasons for their defeat was the
liberalization of the country over the
course of the previous two decades the
shifting away from Traditional Values
such as family the Catholic church and
the honor of the military the only way
to save the country was to remake it in
his own image in essence batal ended up
imitating what Hitler Mussolini had done
in their regimes soldiers and public
officials were required to swear an oath
of loyalty not to the nation but to
patar himself images of the Marshal
appeared everywhere from money to
sculpture attempting to build a cult of
personality around Baton the regime's
revolution National had a new motto
labor family Fatherland the Vichy regime
arrested most of the political leaders
of the country from the last decade who
had remained in France imprisoning them
and subjecting them to trials where the
entirety of the defeat in 1940 was laid
at their feet also imprisoned was anyone
that criticized the government in any
way another popular Target of attack by
Qatar was the British in radio broadcast
the French people Batar accused Britain
of dragging France into a war that they
didn't want and then abandoning them to
the Nazis claiming that they were only
interested in seizing France's overseas
territories for themselves baton and his
ministers particularly his vice Premier
Pierre Laval were attempting to maintain
a delicate Balancing Act trying to Stave
off a complete German takeover of their
country while avoiding outright
collaboration with their conquerors
their two biggest bargaining chips were
the French naval fleet disarmed but
still under their control as well as
France's North African colonies which
they maintained administration of even
though most of them declared for child
gauze free France government in Exile in
London which viewed Vichy as an
illegitimate government set up by
traitors to the nation in order to
appease the Nazis the Vichy government
either willingly or was forced to make
more and more concessions in favor of
collaboration Batar was fiercely
anti-communist coming down on the side
of the Germans when they invaded the
Soviet Union in 1941 and had no qualms
about suppressing leftist dissidents
within France he had a harder time with
the attacks made against France's Jewish
population but did sign laws stripping
French Jews of citizenship and confining
them to internment camps and gave only
token protest when the Germans decided
that they should be shipped off to
concentration camps in Germany Laval
even magnified the Carnage by insisting
that children under 16 which had been
Exempted by the Nazis be deported with
their parents Vichy officials would
later claim that the Germans never told
them they were being sent to their
deaths only that they were being
deported to labor camps in the event
over 70 000 French Jews were murdered
many of them having been arrested and
turned over to the darpo by French
police officers
tall was an odd choice to become an
autocratic dictator Not only was the man
84 years old when he took power he had
also never been elected to a single
political office and had shown almost no
interest in politics that didn't pertain
to the Armed Forces prior to 1940. he
was going deaf his vision was fading and
he tended to nod off during official
meeting sometimes even when he was
speaking he tended to be most active in
the morning pumped up with stimulants by
his personal physician and then he
crashed in the late afternoon and
evening willing to sign almost anything
put in front of him so that they would
leave him alone at times patan was
astonished to discover what exactly had
signed law not having even read the
decrees before putting his signature on
them he deluded himself into believing
that he had been the only man to save
France in its hour of need but now he
was starting to realize that he'd been
wrong about one crucial fact Britain had
not been defeated by Germany and now
both the Soviet Union and the United
States were in the war on the side of
the Allies for the first time he started
to believe that Germany might lose the
war and he began to play a double game
of trying to court both the Allies
especially the US and the Germans at the
same time trying to make sure that he
ended up on The Winning Side at the same
time he grew frustrated with the growing
resistance to the German occupation and
the Vichy collaborators within France
patar came down hard against the French
Resistance labeling them all communist
traitors Laval organized the militia a
collaborationist paramilitary group that
fought the resistance fighters in the
Hills its Leader Joseph Dana was given
extrajudicial powers to summarily
execute enemies of the state upon
capture without trial the resistance
fought back just as brutally targeting
militia and Vichy leaders for
assassination and executing
paramilitaries that fell into their
hands the resistance only continued to
grow in strength however especially
after September 1942 when petos signed a
law that permitted the Germans to deport
hundreds of thousands of French workers
to work as forced laborers in German
factories while they were subjected to
dismal conditions and frequent bombing
raids by the Allies the government had
also agreed to allow more than a million
French soldiers taken prisoner in 1940
to remain imprisoned as part of the
Armistice and they were also put to work
the French economy was in Ruins as the
Germans forced the French to pay for the
privilege of hosting the occupying
troops and seized food and other
resources to feed their own War Machine
food shortages or ramp and especially in
the cities and this only added to the
anger against the Vichy collaborators
who were noticeably not going hungry in
November 1942 the double game came to an
end following the Allied invasion of
French North Africa Operation Torch in
which Vichy French forces put up only
token resistance Hitler demanded either
that Vichy declare war on the Allies or
the rest of the country would be put
under occupation Batar refused and the
Nazis rolled in cities that had been
largely left alone up to that point now
found themselves subject to Nazi
atrocities like those committed by Klaus
Barbie or the Butcher of Leon who while
acting as the head of the city's gestapo
secret police was known to take a
sadistic pleasure in torturing captives
including women and children Barbie is
believed to be personally responsible
for the deaths of 14 000 people
Marshall baton was now little more than
a figurehead still nominally in charge
of France but in practice a prisoner of
the Germans the Allies wanted nothing to
do with him eventually throwing their
support behind to Gaul and oh when they
invaded France in 1944 the Germans
brought the Vichy government with them
when they retreated into Germany in
April 1945 with the German government
and Military collapsing his captors took
him across the border to neutral
Switzerland to Gaul who had once been a
subordinate and bar of petal led the
Swiss authorities know he wouldn't mind
very much if they refused the French
extradition request for the Marshal
allowing him to live out his remaining
days in Exile however baton to fire to
the end insisted on returning to France
where he was arrested and put on trial
for treason patal was more fortunate
than most to even make it to trial the
days following The Liberation saw an
orgy of violent retribution by French
citizens against collaborators with up
to 10 000 of them killed women who had
slept with German soldiers were
humiliated by having their heads shaved
and they were marched through City
streets branded with swastikas Once
order was restored the trials against
collaborators the legal Purge as it was
known would eventually convict some 120
000 French citizens and almost 800 of
them including Pierre Laval and Joseph
dinar were executed potato and trial
began in July 1945. it was not exactly
an impartial proceeding as many of those
tasked with ascertaining his guilt had
been imprisoned by baton during the war
criticizing the vishi regime it wasn't
really a surprise to anybody that he was
convicted on all counts and sentenced to
death to Gaul by now head of the
provincial government of France commuted
a sentence to life imprisonment both
because of his Advanced age and because
he was worried about sparking riots
among baton's remaining supporters the
Marshall now stripped of his uniform and
his medals was transported in November
to the ildu a small island off the
Western French Coast where he was to be
imprisoned in a 19th Century Ford nobody
expected the old man to survive his
gloomy prison for long but incredibly he
lingered on for years growing steadily
more in firm and senile until he finally
died in 1951 at the age of 95. he was
buried on the island and is still there
today despite protests from his
supporters who insist that he should be
buried near the graves of the soldiers
who died of a door as he had wanted one
gang even disinterred the Marshal's
coffin and stole his remains in an
attempt to force the issue in 1973 but
was soon captured and the body was
re-buried
felipator is considered one of the best
defensive generals of the first world
war able to understand the new weapons
and tactics needed to fight this unique
conflict better than almost anyone of
his time he was a man made for his time
as many war heroes are the problem was
he refused to remain in his time he
lingered on far beyond the point when
most people his age would have retired
past the point where most of his
contemporaries were dead and buried
because of this he ended up caught up in
something he probably didn't fully
understand he wasn't the most willing
participant in Nazi atrocities but he
wasn't naive either he either knew what
was going on or he should have many of
his supporters claim that baton was only
a figurehead that the real power behind
the vishi regime lay with committed
collaborationists like Laval even if it
were true which would contradict the
historical record that Batar played an
active role most of the time in the
administration of his state it still
wouldn't excuse the crimes committed by
the government in his name his face was
on the money after all rather than
becoming the savior of the French Nation
patal's children as he called the French
people simply cast him down and moved on
without him re-establishing Republican
Rule and throwing his National
Revolution right in the trash where it
probably belongs in the end pattar
always believed that he would become a
man of Destiny who would change history
and he did
is probably not in the way intended
foreign